[Music]
and it's my right knee is my right boob
but everyone knows is submitted by xx
transpose home q a bold New Zealand
convicted murderer has won a court
battle to wear a toupee in prison
I want to [ __ ] hide my baldness so I
can get a girlfriend in here he argue
that it's his human right and that is
toupee is an artwork that's essential to
his self-esteem [ __ ] yourself esteem you
don't deserve self-esteem if you're
going to pray only to burn so this is
Phillip John and you don't deserve
self-esteem - Kate - it doesn't look
like it'll boost my self-esteem
although the boys had that hairstyle in
like fifth grade I had that [ __ ] he had
murdered the father of a boy that he had
previously sexually abused so he not
only sexually abused the boy but he
murdered his father yes should be
tortured he should not if you want that
to pay they should melt it to her scalp
yeah oh my god I don't understand how
these things happen it's like this
should be a no [ __ ] brainer it's like
for my self-esteem [ __ ] yourself esteem
your [ __ ] murderer you don't have a
human rights at that and a person yeah
what the [ __ ] is going like this will do
I think murderer is okay
depend on de depends on what but a
pedophile no self-esteem I feel like you
should cut his ears off or something how
was like your self-image based on like
something that happens to you like that
a human right how did it pass so before
I get into that I just want to say that
there's other convictions that he had Oh
which includes extortion aggravated
robbery and sexual offences what is just
cut his arms off so because of the
murder he is now serving a life sentence
in prison and so so that happened in
1996 right so in 2014 he was temporarily
released from the prison in Port for
work right but somehow he was able to
get a passport and like
leave the country what yeah and they
still give him a tooth in he actually
fled over to South America and then
eventually he was caught in Brazil and
in Rio is this full from New Zealand PM
using some criminals go to New Zealand
because did you know Elin she said New
Zealand why did you ask I didn't know I
was in the title but I didn't know if he
was from there you know some people
there from a place but it's been quite a
summer I yes when he was when he escaped
right she was actually like wearing his
toupee right and so when he got caught
he had likely to pay as a part of him
right and so when he went into prison
the prison guard started like poking fun
at him like no tickets to pay off and
like they'll just say that it's payback
right and so for for Philip he said that
it was embarrassing and that well don't
want that smart enough to get a passport
and leaf yeah I think he's gonna use it
to pay for bad and maybe smuggle [ __ ]
underneath there or whatever he's
playing he was actually able to get his
TP yeah funky what's the next step with
this toupee
he's going to use it to [ __ ] light
people's jail cells on fire or he's
going to use it to conduct electricity
so now I want to know how he got it I'm
just so curious I gotta know what
happened in court you know it means that
then made that like a cosmetic thing a
human right how do you go to court for
something so true yeah so the judge said
that his fundamental right to freedom of
expression was ignored you don't have
well this is not American a fundamental
right or connects what all song then has
it make a [ __ ] to pee out of the
grass that he finds out and yeah there
you go
[ __ ] you bro yeah let them shave his ass
hairs and glue that [ __ ] to a head [ __ ]
oh yeah yes to come in on the forehead
yeah use that as flute that's a [ __ ]
way more artistic way to do it
yeah no one else has that [ __ ] and
because um local media outlets like
caught this news they like a lot of
people who are reading about this or
something like oh my god dude what is
going on with a new view in prison
system like how is this guy able to flee
the country like how would be able to
obtain hose it let them also work with
the foot yeah it's like they started
like questioning the credibility of
these prisons and they're like she's
been allowing him to human hesita today
why are they so soft so they can't
change it anymore that's it you get just
to pay but it seems like from what I was
reading in the report and he was trying
to ask for more but the judge didn't
usually but is clearly like he declined
his request for damages is genis quickly
he was able to get a passport that's
scary I feel like that front door of a
New Zealand prisoners like normal
spinning door teams there's no guard if
you can make it through just make it
through and people just walking in and
out and in and up ridiculous dude that's
so crazy dude
that's very imaging to me rosealee I
just don't understand like I always
assume that once you commit such a
heinous crime you just don't think they
really you supposed to lose all your
human rights like it doesn't exist
anymore why are people so human righty I
wish I could answer that but know this
this man was abused that's why he had to
murder three hundred people and trap
innocent women in their base in his
basement
oh he's a human too you know he had a
tough childhood so let's just let him
live until he dies what who [ __ ] came
up with that [ __ ] how would you punish
him kill him oh you kill this right off
the bat if he's a murderer and a wing
and a rapist
you can't kill him that's too easy
oh yeah or let him do something that's
like you know if we're going to keep
them alive might as well have them like
ride a bicycle or creates like
electricity or something and he was
doing he's doing something instead of
just sitting there [ __ ] wasting our
food our air whatever
what did you say that those are good
reason you you said my chain gangs yeah
because human rights people came in at
all we all attend you know back what
they like you see like extremely those
guys in the black and white suits and
they have like those chains attached to
their ankle ya know yeah they'll come
out and actually work in the field and
they go back in because of corrupt
for-profit prisons I think they would
keep them in jail for a long time
they're usually black people and they
just kept them there to keep free labor
oh man cuz like I always thought that
was a pretty awesome idea because like I
can't even for me as a prisoner it's
like I'd rather be [ __ ] pulling weeds
in the Sun they're sitting in a Cell all
day they still productive alley and
you're in the outside world for a moment
like it gives you a little bit of your
sanity you get them to build a freeway
to stuff stuff that we need like an L a
nother grade all we need trash pickers
all over the US because I don't think
you need to keep people in prison any
longer our prisons are impacted like we
could use those to all them they could
build a scaler
I mean they do have programs for that
though where prisoners who are going to
come back into like homeboy industries
yeah but they're not like gone I'm
talking about guys that are just gone
like forever yeah like yeah like
licensed yeah these guys just [ __ ] you
know they had a rape van and their whole
lives they were just [ __ ] picking up
people on the rape van [ __ ] them and
killing them that's that's the type of
people I'm talking about these guys like
let me [ __ ] catfish a boy at
McDonald's and say i'ma buy you a happy
meal and you know lure them for sex
those are the kind of guys I'm talking
about when you guys grow bold will you
guys get a wig no no well it depends so
if I'm let's say like in the next five
years I've become bald I'd be pretty
upset
but in 12 years 15 years would you get
to pay like let's say you're still young
right eaglebones did you get a toupee or
would you pay to get like hair
planchet i know that's like crazy
technology which pays now that lasts a
month at a time yeah I seen some that
you can even go swimming like it still
likes crazy stuff because I actually
have an uncle in Korea I didn't know but
he's had a two phases ever like since he
bald be bald and bald it is it he wente
well Harley went bald really early and I
just didn't I only thought it to my
parents told me but his toupee is
amazing would have never known I don't
care with that I can't wait to look like
a kung fu master your hair so they don't
weigh never yeah I think I mean you're
gonna die and your hair's gonna draw
your casket yeah but like how cool is it
to have a perfectly shiny top with a
full set of crust to decline on this
side
is it a coal bit downwards but every
like 80 people is gonna be hella wire
reads like you just woke up yeah my
grandpa's name is [ __ ] why are you
dude like steel wool but it looks so
wide and the shine is so shiny I don't
know this is a lot mom tells me because
she's like a hairdresser but she always
tells my brother never to have the gel
touch your scalp because in your global
like you'll go bald faster because like
the products like sitting in there so
you have to wash it off like everybody
but you have to make sure the scalp like
the product doesn't touch the skull like
[ __ ] is a [ __ ] okay I think
that's her making an obsession about
something without any side to be back
yeah well that might be true for
bleaching cuz I had a friend who always
[ __ ] bleached his bank right here and
he's balding right in that spot biggest
[ __ ] every [ __ ] hilarious is just to
like patches here but its thickest but
like your hair that'd be crazy
hello JK news fans now I know you want
to be a part of our videos and you know
how you do that you go to the [ __ ]
link bellowing is [ __ ] submit some
articles other than that
go check out our videos up here hell
yeah
[Music]